Fabiano you had a full night to sit on
this result how impactful is this
national championship for you yeah it's
always very special for me uh to to win
the US championship and it's been very
difficult in the past for me uh I I went
many years without being able to break
through and last year things went
smoothly this year as well so it's uh
it's very important for me both from the
point of view of uh how strong of a
tournament it is and also from a
personal point of view because it is the
US Championship it's really uh really
huge for me that I I was able to do it
this time because I I know that these
tournament victories don't come easily
and I know from experience and and these
days it gets more and more difficult
especially with the young guys getting
stronger and and they're super motivated
so uh you you have to put a huge amount
of effort into these types of events